bonjour à tous on est aujourd'hui au mwc
à barcelone sur le stand de htc pour
vous parler d'un nouveau produit qui
s'appelle le htc ou aux isles bonne
nouvelle c'est un produit qui est
vraiment bien qui va se positionner
entre le htc et 11 plus et le htc 11
life le point négatif est que c'est un
produit qui pour l'instant n'est pas
disponible en france je suis pas sûr
qu'il devienne un jour normal c'est
intéressant pour regarder un petit peu
le produit qui est un peul entre deux là
où le htc hero the life avait été quand
même relativement décevant je pense que
celui ci en tout cas le u11a ids devrait
être plus intéressant alors ça c'est dur
à prononcer ag c'est une grosse l'ipad
steve niles mélange un peu les pinceaux
qu'est ce que ce smartphone a dans le
ventre il a un processeur snapdragon 650
de 4 gigas de ram 64 giga de stockage
que vous pouvez monter bien évidemment
avec une carte microsd
le monte même jusqu'à deux terrains une
certification ip67 résistant à l'eau et
à la poussière
une caméra arrière de 12 mégapixels avec
une ouverture de f 1.7 une stabilisation
optique bien évidemment un éclairage led
qui trouve son côté une détection de
phase parce que vous mettez en promod
peut faire des photos au format raw
film est bien évidemment en 4k faire un
des photos panoramiques de l'hyper l'aps
du slow motion à 120 images par seconde
en full hd
avant vous avez une double caméra de 5
mégapixels avec une ouverture de f 2.2
vous allez pas le mode 1
bloquer les petits mode saas est un
petit peu standard vous pouvez filmer à
l'avant en full hd
côté batterie vous avez une batterie de
3930 méliand paire eur une recharge
rapide et vous avez à l'avant un grand
écran de 6 pouces alors côté positif de
ce smartphone c'est effectivement le
grand écran 6 pouces en immersion c'est
pas mal côté un peu négatif à l'avant
les grandes bandes que vous avez sur le
haut et sur le bas un écran qui n'est
pas complètement un bord à bord alors
que c'est vrai que c'est un peu le le
format qui s'est imposé en fin d'année
dernière qui continue de s'imposer en
2018 néanmoins il a un design assez
élégant vous avez un dos en verre qui
forcément un inconvénient de laisser des
traces de doigts un capteur d'empreintes
digitales qui va se situer ici
caceres gnomique - là effectivement j'ai
cette espèce de gros antivol qui
m'embête mais d'un point de vue prise en
main je trouve que c'est plutôt pas mal
fichu il n'y a plus de port jack
malheureusement vous avez un haut
parleur ici le bouton pour l'allumer le
bouton de volume qui seront sur le côté
le lecteur de carte sim qui se trouve en
haut
bon après je trouve que en termes de
navigation c'est un produit qui est
plutôt pas mal
qui réagit plutôt bien aujourd'hui qui
est plutôt de bonne qualité
côté photo ça me paraît relativement
correct
c'est pas non plus dingues les facebook
et pas mal parce permet d'élever avec la
double caméra avant donc on n'est pas
que sur un effet deux tiers au niveau
logiciel ce qu'on voit avec ce htc et
aux isles 5 effectivement htc va plus
loin dans sa gamme u11 après le 11 les
11 plus loose light blue eyes
quel sera le prochain on attend htc ou
12 qui on espère pour arriver cette
année
pour l'instant ce produit si vous voulez
la voir il va falloir le faire venir de
chine
néanmoins en tout cas de ce que je vois
c'est un produit que je compte aussi 10
ans comme c'est un produit qui est pas
disponible en france mais pas la
formation à vous donner en tout cas tout
de suite côté prix néanmoins je pense
que c'est un produit comme julien qui
situe entre le live qui est vraiment le
produit d'entrée de gamme de htc de
mont-wright et le 11
plus on doit être un tarif intermédiaire
je voulais un lien dans la description
j'avais fait une recherche comme ça vous
aurez toutes les infos en attendant je
vous remercie d'avancé les sept vidéos
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez y
est ce que vous êtes déjà client de htc
est ce que vous trouvez les premiers
nuages qui est ce intéressant parce que
vous trouvez qu'ils vont plutôt dans le
bon sens avec le nose life avait été
plutôt décevant celui ci semble un petit
peu corriger le tir
sans forcément révolutionner l'histoire
est à dire plutôt pas mal j'attends de
voir un petit peu le u 12 voir ce qui va
donner et s'il arrive vraiment à se
différencier avec ce modèle dites moi
vous ce que vous en pensez mark et moi
tout ça en commentaire vous invite bien
évidemment comme d'hab les cds jolie
pousse à rester connectés parce que on
va parler toujours plus de teck de
smartphones de produits innovants de
robotique énormément de sujets divers et
variés donc restez connectés merci à
vous soyez sages laissez moi vos
commentaires et que très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]